das tagesgespräch bei phoenix heute mit
bernd osterloh dem vorsitzende des
gesamt und konzernbetriebsrats und
mitglied des präsidiums des
aufsichtsrates von volkswagen ich grüße
sie ganz herzlich verbunden mit der
frage wie kommt die autoindustrie durch
die korona krise ja erstmal schönen
guten morgen ich glaube was das thema
kundenaufträge betrifft sind wir
eigentlich relativ gut aufgestellt
leider haben wir das kann man ja auch
jeden tag in der zeitung lesen oder auch
bei ihnen im fernsehen sehen
mittlerweile im zulieferbereich relativ
große probleme gerade was das thema
halbleiter betrifft da ist eben nicht
nur volksbank vom betroffenen sondern
auch andere unternehmen gerade durch die
korona krise in 2020 sind weniger
aufträge an die halbleiterindustrie
rausgegangen und die sind natürlich
genau den bereich elektronik und andere
branchen gegangen und jetzt beim
hochfahren der produktion haben wir
leider festgestellt dass es für den
automobilbereich weltweit zu wenig
halbleiter gibt und das führt natürlich
dazu dass wir das problem haben eben
zuwenig teile für unsere produktion zu
haben also aufträge gibt es genügend und
verkauft wird auch genügend anscheinend
also die autoindustrie scheint das nicht
so hart getroffen zu haben da gibt es
andere dinge die sie hat getroffen haben
ich sag nur diesen skandal und so weiter
und so fort jetzt gibt es einen
sozusagen e mobilitäts mantel den man so
darüber hängt klappt das eigentlich ganz
gut ist die alte krise abgeschlossen
die alte krise ist abgeschlossen ich
glaube wir haben gerade in der letzten
woche bewiesen mit dem thema unserer
batterie weiterentwicklung wie wir uns
vorstellen wir das ganze thema e
mobilität am markt ankommen soll
und auch kommen muss um die co2 vorgaben
zu erreichen
glaube ich sind wir als autoindustrie
aber speziell volkswagen auf dem
richtigen weg auf welchen denn sie
stellen fest dass der 43 mittlerweile
sehr gut verkaufen dass wir eine eigene
batteriefertigung aufbauen und das die
kundennachfrage nach unseren eben nach
unseren autos steigt
das heißt sie bauen eine batteriefabrik
sie setzen auf die batterie autos
sozusagen ich übersetzte für den
normalverbraucher in salzgitter
riesengroß und davon wollen sie noch
eine ganze menge mehr bauen das ist die
zukunft wann geht's los ist die große
frage haben sich schon sich mit der
kanzlerin gestern geeinigt wann der
staat für nur nach elektromobilität und
das aus für den verbrennungsmotor kommt
dann haben wir gestern nicht darüber
gesprochen für mich war gestern in der
runde interessant dass auch
vorstandsvorsitzende von anderen großen
automobilherstellern ja auch einen
großen lkw bereich haben gestern gesagt
gesagt haben das thema
technologieoffenheit ist so aus ihrer
sicht nicht mehr umsetzbar wir müssen
ganz klar auch was das thema lkw und bus
betrifft in richtung batterietechnologie
gehen und ich glaube damit ist auch klar
welcher weg vorgezeichnet ist nämlich
der weg in die mobilität
ja also sind ja derjenige der für die
arbeit da steht der die produktion kennt
und der auch umgefärbt absehen kann
wie läuft das was ist denn so ihre
prognose 2030 2035 amerikaner haben ja
schon ordentlich vorgelegt also
amerikanische automobilindustrie
unternehmen was sagen sie als deutscher
das ist in meinen augen eine
scheindebatte wenn wir die
ladeinfrastruktur und wer meine
interviews liest oder auch am fernsehen
gesehen hat der sagt er wird natürlich
immer wieder vor mir dass meine die
notwendige ladeinfrastruktur brauchen
damit die kundinnen und kunden die e
autos kaufen solange die
ladeinfrastruktur nicht da ist wird
diese form von fahrzeugen auch keinen
absatz haben und ihn verzichten
erforderlichen absetzung die co2
grenzwerte zu erreichen um hendrix
grenzwerte zu erreichen
und deswegen kann ich und das haben wir
gestern auch noch mal ganz klar
gefordert von seiten der
automobilindustrie das thema
ladeinfrastruktur muss noch schneller
vorankommen als bis jetzt geplant er hat
nicht nur in deutschland ich war mit
meinen kolleginnen kollegen von seat von
skoda von audi von volkswagen
nutzfahrzeuge von immerhin waren wir
zusammen in brüssel und haben auch noch
mal ganz klar gemacht dass eine
ladeinfrastruktur eine verbesserte
ladeinfrastruktur eben nicht nur in
deutschland und den skandinavischen
ländern da sein muss sondern natürlich
auch ganz klar ein mittel
mit und osteuropa aufgebaut werden muss
weil man ja in brüssel auch daran
arbeitet neue grenzwerte einzuziehen wo
sie ja wahrscheinlich hoffen dass sie
nicht so heftig ausfallen und dann alles
irgendwie doch wieder zusammenbricht was
man sich so vorgestellt hat wie das die
nächsten jahre noch laufen kann oder
muss da muss ich ihnen ganz offen sagen
das haben wir auch gestern abend
diskutiert also dass die politik uns
zwingt als automobil oder zwingen will
als automobilindustrie in eine alte
technologie noch milliarden euro zu
investieren die war eigentlich
notwendigerweise für das thema e
mobilität brauchen
das erschließt sich mir und meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen egal ob bei
volkswagen daimler und anderen
unternehmen überhaupt nicht und da
wundert mich auch die diskussionen in
brüssel das muss ich ihnen ganz offen
sagen das kann man gut nachvollziehen
eins fehlt mir nach
wasserstofftechnologie sie haben jetzt
nur über elektromobilität geredet also
mit batterie betrieben
vw setzt nicht auf wasserstoff wir
setzen sich auf wasser stoffen ich habe
ja gerade gesagt die diskussion der
kanzler runde kannst du eine runde
gestern abend hat ganz klar gemacht dass
das thema technologieoffenheit
zumindestens für bereich der pkw und lkw
und bus antriebe glaube ich zu ende ist
das klar ist dass wir in richtung e
mobilität setzen
und man muss auch deutlich sagen dass
ich die achtfache achtfache energiemenge
brauche um die gleiche entfernung zu
fahren wie mit ein batterieauto wenn ich
wasserstoff nehme das heißt vw setzt auf
die batterie auf das batterieauto und
ist jetzt so gut schon aufgestellt also
förster aus dem sprung heraus dass wir
zukunftsfähig aus deutschland
exportieren können in deutschland kaufen
können und auch auf dem weltmarkt
mithalten können
das ist glaube ich da bin ich fest von
überzeugt sogar weil wenn man noch mal
guckt 80 prozent der ganzen thema
batterietechnologie der patente kommen
aus deutschland
wenn man das eine die patente hat da
muss man natürlich auch gucken dass man
die industrie die passend dazu aufbaut
und das nicht nur alles den asiaten
überlässt ist für mich ein ganz
wichtiges thema und deswegen auch die
entscheidung der batterie fabrik in
salzgitter und natürlich auch weitere
fabriken in mittel und osteuropa
sicherlich auch wenn es nach dem
betriebsrat geht mir weitere noch in
deutschland das verstehen wir gut
wünschen dabei natürlich gutes gelingen
freuen uns auf die batterien auch aus
salzgitter dankeschön kein osterloh für
das gespräch und die information alles
klar